en dehors des candidats indépendants la
lutte se fait cette année entre deux
parties seulement ces deux partis sont
l'union nationale du premier ministre
antonio barrette et le parti libéral de
jean lesage
elle sera longue la soirée des élections
du 22 juin 1960 la télé fait ses débuts
les ordinateurs aussi au cours de la
soirée le cerveau électronique et bm
nous fournir à ses prédictions ce soir
radio canada
à montréal la lutte est très très serré
l'ordinateur n'y pourra rien comme une
ambiance particulière le soir du 22 juin
1960 oui les libéraux ont gagné mais la
marge semble étroite et la victoire
n'est pas immédiatement et clairement
concédé qu'importe jean lesage n'hésite
pas et je suis tellement contient
d'après les pourcentages je viens
d'avoir sur le pape que nous ayons une
majorité au parlement de l'audace il en
fallait au nouveau chef libéral pour
prédire dès le déclenchement de
l'élection la défaite de la puissante
union nationale au pouvoir depuis 20 ans
ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce sont
d'anciens chefs qui disait
gouvernement de +15 est un gouvernement
corrompu il est le temps que ça change
c'est le slogan libéral mais une
victoire était loin d'être évidente les
électeurs québécois sont plutôt désabusé
et québécois avait pas beaucoup
d'attentes par rapport à la classe
politique et à la politique en général
jugeait que le parti libéral serait
probablement aussi corrompu que l'union
nationale car les historiens s'entendent
pour dire que maurice duplessis décédé
brusquement le 7 septembre 1959 à l'âge
de 69 ans aurait probablement été réélu
son dauphin paul sauvé aussi avait
toutes ses chances mais il décède lui
aussi d'une crise cardiaque en janvier
1960 antonio barrette chef improbable
devient premier ministre et déclenché
des élections et nous on est la
prochaine plénière une loi naturelle
hospitalisation il n'a pas vraiment de
programme d'ailleurs les affiches
électorales d'union nationale montre
serein du plessis sauver et antonio
barrette donc on insiste sur la
continuité donc il ya un parti qui veut
surfer sur ses acquis des années 50
finale
au contraire le parti libéral et rajeuni
le parti libéral du québec s'est
métamorphosée durant les années 50 parti
libéral du québec s'est doté d'une
structure nouvelle beaucoup plus
démocratique a créé ce qu'on appelle la
la fédération libéral du québec et donc
c'est on devient membre du parti libéral
et on est consulté sur les grandes
orientations et c'est un congrès à la
chefferie qui va désigner jean lesage en
1958 comme le chef du parti et non pas
le simplement le caucus et surtout c'est
une équipe pour ne recruter des vedettes
paul gérin lajoie candidat à la
chefferie en soit 58,1
constitutionnaliste rené lévesque
évidemment une star de la télévision de
radio canada donc on recrute de
nouvelles têtes d'affiché qui peut on
dit du tonnerre une équipe nouvelle pas
de programme à l'union nationale mais
une stratégie
le parti de ce chef qui est posée par
l'organisation centrale libéral l'hymne
national a essayé de faire peur aux
électeurs à l'origine nationale c'est de
faire part sur les sur deux tableaux de
tableau du communisme et rené rené
lévesque est une cible mais aussi donc
en disant qu'avec les libéraux ce serait
le socialisme l'état serait partout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de publicité télé fait ses débuts
aujourd'hui grâce à l'union nationale
notre population des liquides de
services hospitaliers préventif
incomparable en 1960 on n'entre pas tout
de suite dans la révolution tranquille
dont alors justement c'est que ce
programme libéral de 1960 n'annonce pas
par exemple nationalisation
d'hydroélectricité n'annonce pas la
création du ministère de l'éducation
parce que ça aurait trop fait peur à
l'église
la nationalisation d'électricité c'est
rené lévesque qui valent à piloter elle
est au coeur de l'élection anticipée
librement et fièrement la première et la
plus importante les clés d'une économie
moderne ça veut dire la nationalisation
début et fin de deux époques qu'on
appellera plus tard la révolution
tranquille et la grande noirceur du
duplessisme sur laquelle le rideau sera
tiré
[Applaudissements]